in texas this week a civil forfeiture
hearing took a wrong turn
when the county attorney rod ponton
accidentally left a cat filter on his
zoom
so all of the parties privy to this
forfeiture hearing
uh zoomed into the call and you see a
judge and you see people wearing suits
and then there's this one county
attorney who would appear to be a
big fluffy cat and the
older gentlemen who were on this call
tried to figure out
how to proceed with the hearing despite
the presence of the
the giant cat i believe you have a
filter turned on in the video settings
you might want to uh uh
we're trying to can you hear me judge
i can hear you i think it's a filter
it is and i don't know how to remove it
i've got my assistant here she's trying
to but
oh i'm prepared to go forward with it
that's i'm here live that's not i'm not
a cat
i can i can see that i
i believe you uh mr attorney that you
are not a cat
uh though that is certainly the sort of
thing a cat would say if you were trying
to
crash a civil forfeiture hearing the
thing about that legal hearing
is that it was still much more serious
and productive than the
fake impeachment trial that's going on
in washington dc right now
i'm michael knowles as the michael
knowles show welcome back to the show my
favorite comment
yesterday was from frosted ice pharaoh
who says that peta
has informed us all that the debate for
goat g.o.a.t athlete
is uh anti-animal a secretariat is the
undisputed
greatest athlete of all time true there
was some debate with seabiscuit but
but certainly it is not tom brady in a
world as
bizarre and and upside down is r is very
important to protect yourself and your
data online make sure
you go to expressvpn there has never
been a more important time to protect
your internet activity than
right now which is why i urge you to get
expressvpn
everything you search for watch or click
online can be tracked by big tech
companies
they can then match your activity to
your true identity using your device's
unique ip address
when i switch on expressvpn with my
computer or phone my ip address is
masked by a secure vpn server
which makes it harder for websites to
identify me the expressvpn app also
encrypts my network data
to protect my sensitive information from
being compromised plus
you can use expressvpn on up to five
devices simultaneously so multiple users
on your network can stay safe with a
single subscription if you are listening
to this show
something tells me you might look at
some unsavory
politically incorrect things on the
internet you know what i'm talking about
open up that incognito window maybe you
go to i don't know dailywire.com
don't let the isps find out stop handing
over your data to the big tech companies
go with the vpn that i trust for
protection visit expressvpn.com
michael to get three months free on a
one year package exp or essvpn.com
michael to get three extra months free
go to expressvpn.com
michael right now to learn more six
republican senators
six republican senators voted with the
democrats
to continue this farce this fake
impeachment trial of the ex-president
in washington d.c you had generally
speaking all the republicans were
against it because it's a sham and it's
unconstitutional
generally speaking you had all the
democrats for it because it's a sham and
it's unconstitutional which democrats
tend to enjoy
and then you had these six squish
useless republicans their names are
bill cassidy of louisiana susan collins
of maine
lisa murkowski of alaska mitt romney of
utah
ben sasse of nebraska and pat toomey of
pennsylvania
these people are
losers i don't i don't know how else to
put it you know i try not to use that
kind of
blunt language all the time i'm i don't
usually do my impression of don rickles
or donald trump for that matter
but there's no other way to put it these
guys are just losers
they may be illiterate i'm not sure i i
thought mitt romney was an intelligent
guy he founded bain capital that's
pretty impressive
ben sasse i think has a phd
but it would appear that they can't read
they certainly can't read the plain text
of the constitution
which makes it very clear even if you
had no other
historical or political sense
or or knowledge surely you could read
the constitution which shows
beyond a shadow of a doubt that this
proceeding is preposterous
let's get into the constitution we've
alluded to it many times
as we've been talking about this sham
impeachment hearing
but let's just get to the plain text
where does impeachment come from
kind of impeachment we're talking of the
president of the united states comes
from two
sections of the constitution article 2
section 4
reads the president vice president and
all civil
officers of the united states shall be
removed from office on impeachment
for and conviction of treason
bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors
donald trump is on trial right now sort
of in d.c
donald trump is neither the president
nor the vice president nor any civil
officer of the united states
as such he cannot be removed from office
notice i don't even need to get into how
preposterous it is
that they are what are they accusing him
of treason
how what what's the argument they don't
have any argument bribery no
they sort of tried that one that didn't
quite work high crimes and mr
what's the crime what's the i'm not even
getting into that i'm just saying it's a
purely technical matter
the guy doesn't meet the criteria but
then it's even clearer when you get into
article one section three
which reads the senate shall have the
sole power
to try all impeachments okay we've that
that's working out right because the
senate is
holding whatever this trial is
goes on though when sitting for that
purpose
they the senate shall be on oath or
affirmation
when the president of the united states
is tried
the chief justice shall preside and no
actually i want to pause right there
just to underscore the point
the president of the united states is
not being tried
so therefore this is not a
constitutional impeachment trial
furthermore the chief justice of the
supreme court is not presiding
some random democrat senator is
presiding
therefore this does not meet the
constitutional criteria of an
impeachment trial
the article goes on no person shall be
convicted
without the concurrence of two-thirds of
the members present judgment in cases of
impeachment
shall not extend further than to this is
very important
shall not extend further than to removal
from office
and disqualification to hold and enjoy
any office of honor trust or profit
under the united states
goes on so
there there can't be some additional
consequences but
but beyond that the only consequence
that you can have for this trial is
removal from office and not removal from
office or
removal from office and the prohibition
that you you can't run for office again
the one tangible thing that the
democrats think they can try to get here
is they can prevent trump from running
for president again
because they're so confident that he did
poorly in 2020 right that's why that's
why they're holding this
unprecedented sham impeachment trial
right because they're so confident that
they're so much more popular
joe biden most popular guy ever elected
right uh probably not their actions
would would seem to undermine that
contention
but furthermore
there cannot be that consequence here
because
the consequence of impeachment is
removal from office and
the prohibition from running again they
can't remove him from
office they can't remove him from office
because he's not in office
they can't do any of those things
because he's not the president
that's why they can't hold a legitimate
impeachment trial
and these people these six republican
losers
i've i've just had it with them i i
always try to say well you know susan
collins she's in a tight spot
i'm requesting yeah romney did this one
like sort of semi-okay thing maybe once
i don't know
he's a good family man that's what you
always say about politicians that you
can't say anything nice about you say
he's a good family man ben sass i sound
i guess he's sort of says conservative
things sometimes
but then he doesn't act in a
conservative manner but
i'm at my wit's end if these guys can't
read the text of the constitution
stand up for something that actually
matters then then what's
what's the point of them
they i guess i guess the point of them
is
this category that we've been talking
about on the show a lot which is they
are
court jester conservatives they exist
to do a little soft shoe do a little
dance kind of pretend to say some
conservative things and then ultimately
to legitimize the liberal regime their
job is ultimately
to lose i was thinking you know forget
that you guys can't read the
constitution
even if they could read the constitution
they clearly don't understand politics
democrats would never do this sort of
thing because it's politically
masochistic
it's not based on any principle it's
just it's just
so so wrong so i thought maybe these
guys just don't understand the politics
but then i thought you know maybe they
do understand the politics
maybe they do understand the politics
and they're just not
on our side that's even worse isn't it
either way this
this really should be the end of their
political careers i guess
it probably won't be but it certainly
should be you know sometimes politics is
relatively
friendly relatively it's the key word
here is relatively sometimes it's
truly vicious we are much closer
to the latter end of things at the
moment
anderson cooper sums this up on cnn
when anderson cooper was talking about
you know unity and healing and how we
need to be inclusive and tolerant
we can't otherwise people as
he compares
basically every republican to the worst
sort of killers
genocidal maniacs most vicious people in
the history of the world
you know part of it i think just based
on what you were just saying
it comes to mind the idea of other
rising people is something i think we
saw a lot of over the last four years i
mean something we've seen a lot over the
last
decades but it's so easy to otherwise
people to make people other than
other than american other than patriotic
other than human
you know and we've seen it in bosnia
we've seen it in rwanda where radio was
telling
people that you know who jews were
telling the radio listeners the tutsi
were cockroaches
for you know getting them jinned up for
genocide
um and you see it in in these videos
where
people who claim they are patriots are
in the face of a police officer calling
him
uh you know as we're seeing it right
there yeah gosh could you imagine if the
left
ever said anything mean to or about the
police
you know like all of 2020 no but that
forget about that we're just talking
about the republicans for a moment here
because
you see we don't want to otherwise
we don't want to other the republicans
are otherwising people you know as awful
vicious deplorable irredeemable
republicans
those neo-nazi there they are other
rising people
you know those republicans who are who
are just like the genocidal regime
in rwanda you know them those people
they have nothing redeeming about them
and we need to ostracize them from the
country they're so evil and terrible
they're otherwising people you see and
it's very bad to otherize people
why if you otherwise people you'd be
like those republican cockroaches
who need to be rooted out pull them out
of the country darn it
does anderson cooper not know what he's
saying he probably knows what he's
saying he probably knows
how ironic what he's saying is but he
doesn't care he's just he is other
rising people right he's projecting in
the way the left always projects
and these snakes these snake republicans
want to join i'm talking about the real
snake republicans i'm otherwising mitt
romney and company
they are joining in an unconstitute
unconstitutional proceeding aimed at not
just donald trump but aimed at
all the rest of us
not good not good you know you can't
trust these people very you know
people i can't trust or when i go to an
auto parts store and i ask for a certain
auto part and then you know they go in
the back and then they don't have it and
then they go and they charge me twice as
much
i can't trust those guys you know who i
can trust rockauto.com love rockauto.com
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
20 years online that's like the whole
history of online go to rockauto.com to
shop for auto and body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers best of
all prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low
and the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts the rockauto.com catalog
is unique it's remarkably easy to
navigate it is so easy to navigate
that even i can do it you can quickly
see all the parts available for your
vehicle
and choose the brands specifications and
prices that you prefer they have an
amazing selection
they also always have reliably low
prices so it's not always gimmicks and
you got to wait until a certain day to
go order it
just they always have reliably low
prices they got all the parts you're
going to need head on over there don't
over pay
at the brick and mortar store that's not
even going to have your parts in stock
anyway go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck
write knowles k-w-l-e-s in their how did
you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you while
the democratic party is comparing
most republicans virtually all
republicans
to uh genocidal dictators
to neo-nazis to all sorts of terrible
things
these six republicans the sort of mitt
romney ben sasse types
these guys murkowski collins they're
joining with the democrats
we should strongly consider kicking them
out of the republican party
this is a different matter than liz
cheney i i want to be very
specific here liz cheney did something
that i think was extremely stupid and i
disagree with and i wish that the
republican party did not include
you know these sorts of ideas i wish liz
cheney would come over to the
conservative way of thinking
but what liz cheney did was
justifiable liz cheney a member of the
house
republican leadership too but a member
of the house voted
to impeach the then sitting duly elected
president donald trump
even though he was a member of her own
party even though there was no good
argument for impeachment
she voted her conscience her conscience
might be faulty but she voted her
conscience
that was a legitimate vote the the vote
that the house
took before trump left office was
arguably a legitimate impeachment vote
so i don't think liz cheney should be
kicked out of the republican party she
probably should be removed from
leadership
because she doesn't represent i think
most republicans certainly not the base
but she shouldn't be kicked out of the
party
what these senators are doing sas romney
murkowski all of them they're doing
something very different they are
engaging in an
anti-constitutional charade that is
upending
american political norms that is illegal
that is vicious that is politically deaf
and that is
constitutionally illiterate they
should not remain in the republican
party they there's a reason that these
people are getting censure votes there's
a re
it's not just because the kooky crazy
base doesn't understand the
brilliant moderation and madisonian
temperament of these people
it's because they're wrong they're
they've betrayed their party
they've betrayed the constitution and
they're
just bad politicians and they're losers
and i don't see
what benefit they bring to the party or
to the country
i think i've made my position on these
people clear clear enough
these guys these snakes in the grass are
towing
the white house line on impeachment
frankly they're going further than the
white house
you know jen saki is is asked
our favorite press secretary right now
because she's the only press secretary
jen saki is asked about the the white
house's opinion on
on the quote-unquote impeachment trial
she won't even go out on a limb and say
oh it's definitely constitutional or
it's this or it's that
she's being actually fairly circumspect
in her answers
the the quote-unquote republican
senators six of them
are much further to the left on this
question even than the white house
listen to her answer
on the constitutionality of the trial
does he see it as constitutional
i don't think that's for me or us to
opine on obviously he said that the
process should proceed and it's doing
exactly that
it's not for us to opine on of course it
is for you to opine on
you are one of the three branches of
government and impeachment directly
involves the white house right who gets
tried
during normal impeachment trials the
president gets tried we're in this kind
of weird world
this bizarro world where a private
citizen is being tried at a senate
impeachment trial
but ordinarily this would involve the
white house so surely you have a reason
to opine on it the reason she doesn't
want to opine
is because this is constitutionally
absurd and the logical next step is
going to be whenever the republicans
have the house maybe they don't even
need to have the senate but especially
if they did have the senate
what would be the logical next step is
to just impeach some ex-democrat
president
barack obama did many many dodgier
things than donald trump
barack obama committed what i think are
actual impeachable offenses
so we'd have to get a little more in the
in the detail on what happened during
the 2016 election
when barack obama's administration spied
on his political rival donald trump
seems seems wrong to me seems like an
abusive power to me
seems criminal to me or when barack
obama used his
irs to target his political opponents
seems criminal to me
or when or when or when
many such examples so good i can't wait
i can't wait till republicans get the
house
and we can impeach barack obama well no
michael you understand
trump was impeached by the house when he
was still in office but
he's being tried after he left office
okay well that's a subtle distinction
that's not going to matter in the future
because it's completely disingenuous but
fine okay we'll wait until
we can impeach the democrat president
while he's sitting and then we'll try
him after he's left off is fine
fine obviously the white house doesn't
want this sort of thing they don't want
joe biden to be tried
however many years from now so jen saki
is not going to give a direct answer
she's just going to speak in broad tones
because they like the fact of the
impeachment trial but they don't want to
go on the record saying
they support it so what do they talk
about they go back to
sort of platitudes about incendiary
rhetoric
as millions of people tune in to watch
this trial presumably throughout the
week they're going to see
the former president's lawyers argue
based on the briefs that they have filed
that some democrats have used incendiary
rhetoric they are going to point to
representative maxine waters for example
who in 2018
called on supporters at a rally to
confront and at one point harass
trump officials over their support of
the child separation policy the
zero tolerance policy that's something
that cedric richmond
said she had a constitutional right to
express those views
so how does the white house view that as
any different
look the president is joe biden is the
president he's not a pundit
he's not going to opine on the back and
forth arguments
um nor is he watching them that are
taking place uh in the senate
so that that was a very good question
from the reporter actually
occasionally you get a good question in
these white house briefings and jen saki
obviously has no answer
has no answer because th this is this is
the political aspect that drives me
crazy about these snake in the grass
fake republicans at the fake impeachment
trial at least
i'll say nominal republicans they are
registered republicans they're members
of the party for now
is they they they seem very eager
to attack the president for
actually calling for peaceful political
demonstrations
but then one of them turned violent for
a few hours
they they don't seem particularly
interested in holding
democratic politicians feet to the fire
when they actually called for
violent political violence against
republicans maxine waters
hillary clinton eric holder kamala
harris
not only supporting the violence but
actually bailing the violent rioters out
of prison
out of jail rather these
these republicans are basically nowhere
to be found mitt romney marched with blm
right blm spends much of 2020
burning the country to the ground
ripping down our statues
setting businesses on fire setting
government buildings on fire and there's
mitt romney principled mitt romney
marching with them
an an explicitly marxist organization
the founders of it saying we are
marxists recently patrice cullers who
was one of the founders of blm came out
she said look there's been a lot of
misinformation
people are saying i'm a marxist well i
am she actually did a video thing like
yeah
yeah i am you got me an organization
that says there they exist to undermine
the western prescribed nuclear family
they finally nuked that from their about
us page but it was up for a very very
long time you can still find it
in the internet archives mitt romney
marches with them but he's got to stand
on principle
because trump said that there might have
been election irregularities he
and in frank you know what i'm i'm even
willing to grant maybe his rhetoric was
a little bit
uh trumpian you know is a little
hyperbolic perhaps
but he was calling attention to
something there were many many
many irregularities in some cases in the
election
there was an outright violation of the
state constitution
in the way the election was held
so i'm not i'm not even defending
the trump rhetoric all i'm pointing out
is the rank hypocrisy
from these so-called principled
conservatives who give the left a pass
for doing much much much worse sort of
stuff and take every opportunity
to jump at the republicans
there's a lot of uh a lot of hypocrisy
here you know the new york times
oh bring it back to the new york times
new york times recently
fired one of their writers i think he
was a science writer because years ago
he said the n-word you know the i'm not
if i say the n-word right now even just
to give you context for it i'll
probably be sent to the bull log so i'm
just saying the n-word right he said the
n word but he actually said the word
just in context to say well if you say
this word what does that mean
he was fired for saying that in a
private conversation years ago
new york times says we have a zero
tolerance policy on the n-word
never going to say this is the executive
editor dean beckett
managing editor joe khan but it turns
out
uh nicole i'm sorry hannah nicole jones
who's the head of the anti-american 1619
project she has said the n-word publicly
now we've been told the new york times
says doesn't matter the context if you
ever utter the n-word let's say you're
reading huck finn
out loud if you ever say you can't work
at the new york times
do you think they're going to fire
hannah nicole jones no they have a they
have a sort of
hierarchy and certain people get to say
certain things certain people don't
new york times by the way it's a sort of
amusing
exercise just if you look up that word
on the new york times archive the new
york times were using that left and
right
until quite recently actually but now
now there's a special rule the rule only
applies to some people though of course
that's
that's how it works at the times and on
the left broadly
matt walsh is going to be getting more
into this fake impeachment trial he's
going to be
getting into the left wing conspiracy
theorists
who are i kid you not i did see this i'm
interested to hear matt's take on it
because i only saw the headlines
they're trying to make the cracker
barrel logo
into a racist dog whistle cracker barrel
you know like that great down home
country store and restaurant yeah
they're trying to make that into a uh
there's a secret subliminal racist dog
whistle
you know the left seems to be the only
people who hear these dog whistles
so does but doesn't that mean therefore
that the left are
i don't doesn't make them cats doesn't
make them cats
you know a daily wire membership is the
only way that you should be viewing our
content
because if you look you can get it on
apple podcast spotify stitch or
all over the place but if you're doing
it there instead of the daily where
you're missing out on some terrific
features right now
using promo code knowles you will get 10
off
of any member plan that you choose what
makes membership so great well
members get access to our articles ad
free access to all of our live
broadcasts show library two full hours
of the ben shapiro show
and our always growing catalog of
content plus with our all access
membership
you will also receive two of the
greatest of all beverage vessels the
leftist year's tumbler
you will get all of that and a lot more
by the way plus ten percent off when
using promo code no scanner wles
so stop depriving yourself come join the
fun we'll be right back with a lot more
racial politics seeping into everything
these days creating
lots of hypocrisy at the new york times
now possibly affecting cracker barrel
have absolutely contrived non-traversing
there and of course affecting
aunt jemima poor aunt jemima pour one
out pour out some syrup
for our dearly departed aunt jemima who
you'll recall during the george floyd
riots for some reason everyone decided
that we could no longer tolerate
a beloved syrup icon any longer
so aunt jemima got the boot uh you can
no longer see her face i didn't realize
they're getting rid of her face her
character they're they're also getting
rid of the name
so and it actually it's very stupid and
kind of amusing how they did this but
it does have political implications
the anshumayama pancake syrup is now
called the pearl
milling company syrup and there's no
lady on it anywhere there's no person
it's just kind of a building they call
it pearl
milling company and
it's it's lame it's like the it's like
the mitt romney of
pancake syrups now this is ironic of
course because
in the name of racial justice these
white liberals mostly white liberals
have taken a job away from a black woman
namely to be the spokesman of uh of aunt
jemima now of course aunt jemima was a
fictional character but aunt jemima was
portrayed
by a very famous model
uh nancy greene who uh she portrayed
aunt jemima at the 1893
world's colombian exposition in chicago
she was one of the first black
corporate models in the united states
that's a great accomplishment
isn't it well that accomplishment is now
being stripped from this black lady
in the name of racial justice for black
people now
part of the reason for this is they say
sure nancy greene good for her she was
the model but
she was participating in a minstrel act
you see the character aunt jemima she's
not all well and good she's actually a
sort of old stock
character from those racist minstrel
shows
and therefore sure you know she had this
accomplishment but we got to wipe it
away
because minstrel c is racist
now the further irony that a lot of
people don't know here is that
the the minstrel character aunt jemima
was created by billy chrysans
a black guy a black comedian who
participated in the minstrel shows
in the 1870s very very well-known black
comedian
he created the character old aunt jemima
so in the name of woke
racial equality pro
black i don't know you're taking away a
beloved black character
portrayed by a famous black woman
invented by a famous and beloved black
man
so that you can replace all of that with
a building and the pearl milling company
the the
political aspect to this well first of
all
there's just a general political aspect
in that they're pushing for racial
equality but they're undermining
various racial accomplishments but the
the other political aspect is
i think undergirding a lot of this is
the
belief that particularity is
wrong particularity is wrong
sort of abstraction generalization is
good
because when you get into details when
you get into particularity
things get a little weird things get a
little more complicated you especially
see this with our history
so for the left they say yeah all the
old people that's founded america and
developed the country
bad because you know america was racist
i guess that's the go-to term it's just
now a synonym for bad
everything is racist now right you know
cracker barrel's racist for some reason
cracker barrel and the term could be
racist against white people right
because
cracker is a derogatory term for whites
but it's not just it just refers to a
barrel that crackers were put in
but everything now is called racist if
you want to get rid of it so you say
okay all those old people in the past
and the bad old timey days they were
really bad we got to get rid of them but
then you get into the specifics you said
what about george washington gosh that
guy seems pretty
noble honorable thomas jefferson a
complex guy
you know no question had some faults as
do we all but
you know also a very very great man all
these sorts of people billy chrysans the
guy who invented aunt jemima gosh how
was he he was participating in this
minstrel c which is bad you know by it's
one of the most prominent forms of
american theater right it's an actual
american contribution
to the theater it's got all it's very
problematic as we say now but
you know it did did happen it actually
has a role in theater history and had
black performers and black writers
involved in it but
we're not allowed to say that anymore
we're not allowed to get into the
specifics you got to
erase billy chrysans you got to erase
nancy greene
you got to erase aunt jemima just as
surely as you've got to erase
george washington and thomas jefferson
and andrew jackson and
abraham lincoln all for the abstraction
this kind of perfect world that doesn't
in any way
partake of of human nature it's a big
difference between the left and the
right
you know you think about what they did
the french revolution the french
revolution took away
they come in they take away all local
affections they take away all
old neighborhoods all old towns all old
loyalties and and rituals and they
replace them with just a
perfectly geometric country they're just
going to divide the country up in this
perfect geometric way they're going to
redo the whole calendar in this perfect
geometric way
they're going to take away all religious
affections and make it make them all
about the abstractions to reason
something like that and what does that
do
the theory is the theory is once you
take away
details local affections particularity
specificity
then people are going to transfer the
loyalties they had to those sorts of
things
to the the broader kind of contrived
national or international group but
that's just not what happens
people don't people don't have loyalty
or affection to the united nations right
nobody goes out waves the united nations
flag
at a sports game or something what you
do
you undermine the local affections the
local loyalties the local
feeling of duty but you don't replace it
with anything
you just get people who are sort of
uprooted who just have no
who feel transgender who feel no bonds
to anything
this actually ties into the super bowl
it does in the same political manner you
know
this super bowl was the lowest watched
super bowl
in over a decade uh it had fewer than
100 million viewers
even though the game itself i guess was
kind of boring but you know tom brady
gets a seventh ring that's pretty
impressive especially with the with the
new team
so see cbs viacom are saying yeah it was
fewer than 100 million
viewers um so you know that's that's no
good you got to figure out how to turn
this around what's responsible for it
partially it's the people are unplugging
you know i i don't
pay for cable i i don't think i've ever
signed up to get cable you know in my
entire adult life
just stream things and so part of it is
the legacy media they're losing
a lot of ground virtually no millennial
that i know
or zoomer that i know has cable or pays
for cable
um so part of it's the technological
aspect
part of it too though is as that goes
away
as you know the common tv as the common
slate of movies is the
as that all goes away people are
returning to
affinity groups you know the odds that i
would
watch the super bowl are pretty low
anyway i'm just not not the biggest
football guy in the world
but maybe you know in the old days when
we were all watching the same things
maybe i'd go to a super bowl party or
at least i get to gamble and smoke a
cigar or something but now
i'm i'm less interested in that because
just people are breaking up into
different interest groups
the internet is helping to do that right
you can spend a lot of time in your own
echo chamber and
we we speak of this in a bad way but the
good way is you get to spend a lot of
time in your own interests
right i'm not i'm not interested in most
of what is on network television so i
just ignore it i just don't watch it i'm
not interested in most of what's on
cable television either so i'll go on
the internet and i'll get to watch
exactly what i want i get to read
exactly what i want
that's sort of nice in a way this is a
return to normal
you know in the mid 20th century just
for even a little earlier than that
mass media just took the whole nation's
attention
and drew it in on itself and we talk
about those halcyon days
when we could rely on objective
journalists like you know walter
cronkite or something
but that was probably the single
greatest tool
of liberalism in america right i mean
walter cronkite mr tell it like it is mr
objective the guy was a world federalist
the guy was a radical left winger and he
hit it sort of well but then every so
often he loses the vietnam war you know
every so often it really comes out
in fact much of what conservatives have
tried to do over the past 20 30 years
is try to break up that that lock on our
attention
that that the liberal establishment had
before you had this kind of mass media
especially television in the 20th
century
you had more local affinities
you know there was there was a much
bigger difference between uh i don't
know
alabama and new york much
much greater difference now people lived
what people were interested in
uh the way society was structured
before you had television kind of
homogenize the whole culture it's not
this
isn't just happening in the united
states this happened in italy
the construction of a national culture
there was brought about largely by
television
you see the the loss of a lot of italian
dialects
specific customs when they got more of a
national identity
now it seems after that homogenization
we're all kind of breaking up again but
we're not breaking up down to little
geographic areas
alabama and new york are actually pretty
similar now most when you go i've
traveled
all over this country i've traveled to
probably most of this country you know
when you when you think of major cities
and states
the country is a lot more similar than
it is different and i'm not sure that
that was true 100 years ago
now we're breaking up into affinity
groups again but they're virtual they're
digital
you might have a handful of people who
have a shared interest in
new york alabama alaska and timbuktu
and they're they're sharing experience
together
they're sharing a way a way to view the
world a a
sort of emotional process they're
sharing art they're sharing culture
it might be living next to people who
have a completely different culture and
sharing it
around the globalized world that
that is going to happen and it's it's
going to pose a serious problem for
politics
you know we we've had various political
orders in
in the world over over this millennia
and
uh just as the rise of sort of the piece
of west failure the end of the religious
wars the creation of the nation state
uh created a certain world order
presumably this
huge social upheaval that has occurred
digitally and through the internet that
is going to create
some other kind of order it's going to
change the order a little bit is it
globalism or is it a focus on
particularism right now you're seeing
both actually at the same time
being pushed and a lot of our political
debates come down to that sort of thing
you know one affinity group that we're
seeing is uh
is among american
politically minded people right
everything has become politicized
in the sense that everything has taken
on a partisan character
uh this is a large topic of of my book
that's coming out soon speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which you can pre-order right now
wherever you order your books
but it focuses in on the rise of
political correctness from 1920
to 2020 because political correctness
grew for a lot longer than a lot of
people think it did people came up
became aware of it in the 80s and 90s
really it predates it it was a very
intentional sort of strategy and one of
the
aspects of this that occurred really in
the 70s through the radical feminists
was to politicize everything that the
personal had to become the political the
most
intimate sort of choices and
interactions had to become political
political choices so
now you know you can buy the
conservative running shoes or the
liberal running shoes you can buy the
conservative coffee
or the liberal coffee this is true now
of pillows
so you know there's mike lindell who has
advertised on this show
before uh who makes a fabulous product
my pillow
is advertised on a lot of conservative
networks he has my pillow now david hogg
who became a sort of celebrity after the
parkland shooting
and he formed all these various groups
and stumped for a lot of candidates and
you know made made himself a sort of a
sensation
he's founding a rival pillow company now
there's some question as to whether or
not they're actually going to do the
pillow company
because they say oh yes we're going to
start this pillow company he's teamed up
with an internet troll
whose name i think is william legate or
legate
and so i don't know if it's real or if
it's just kind of a publicity stunt
they were asking you know basically how
to do it how do you make a pillow
company so i don't know that it's really
going to happen but even the idea that
this is a story
shows you something about the state of
our culture so you have my pillow
on the right and some people are calling
david hogg's company
mao pillow on the left uh it's not a bad
idea
you might have some copyright issues in
china but china doesn't care about
copyrights anyway so
you know go for it uh
how much further does that go well this
will this affect every single
product will the quality of the product
matter you know mike lindell he's not
paying me to say this right now right he
didn't buy any ads on the show today
the man makes a great pillow okay say
what you will you might hate his
politics
the man makes a magnificent pillow will
uh
mr hogg make a good pillow i don't know
maybe will it matter
i don't know i don't know that it will
or will people's affinity
for these political issues overcome it
you know mike lindell uh you know sort
of he's an eccentric character in public
life he's always made himself out to be
he goes on the commercials he goes on
media a lot
but when when that coronavirus really
kicked up earlier in 2020
mike lindell went in he said i'm
converting some factories from making
sheets and pillowcases
i'm going to make masks and i have some
of mike lindell's masks and they're
excellent masks they're the most
breathable comfortable masks that i have
i don't even know if he sold them i
think he may have just donated them or
something
that was a long time ago that was back
in march and
april in may and june we're told okay
you know the masks you gotta wear them
but it's only
15 days to slow the spread now we're
coming up on a year
of this presumably
we should be done with the masks right
the vaccine is out there
it's been going on a long time i never
wear the mask and i've been fine
all year knock on wood you know uh
we're now being told that the masks are
going to have to endure
much much longer dr fauci
the exalted dr fauci who famously told
us not to wear masks
that it's stupid to wear masks there's
no reason during an outbreak to wear
masks only gives you a full sense of
security
then he told us you have to wear the
masks then he didn't wear the masks
himself he wore them on camera but then
when he thought he was off camera he
didn't wear them
even when he was around people even
people not in his household
then dr fauci said it's stupid to wear
multiple masks
then dr fauci said you have to wear
multiple masks it's a very good idea to
wear multiple masks
right he said there's no data there's no
evidence to show that the multiple masks
work then he said well it's common sense
then he goes back and forth and back and
forth fauci now says
we're going to need to wear masks until
the end of this year
if we can get and i have used this as an
estimate it's not definitive
that if we can get 70 to 85 percent of
our population
vaccinated and get to what we would hope
would be to a degree
of hurt immunity which really is an
umbrella
or uh or a veil of protection against
the community
where the level of virus is so low it's
not a threat at
all then at that point you could start
thinking in terms of not having to have
uniform
wearing a mask but we're certainly not
near there yet
when do i think that would occur you
know it's very difficult to predict
brett but if everything falls into the
right place and we get this under
control
it is conceivable that you might be able
to pull back
a bit on some of the public health
measures as we get into the late
fall of this year but there's no
guarantee of that because if we don't
get
the overwhelming majority of the
population vaccinated there's still
going to be a considerable amount
of virus in the community and as long as
that's the case brett
people are going to have to wear masks
dr
fauci in march of 2020. masks are very
stupid
no one should wear them they give you a
false sense of security
do not wear the masks there is no reason
now to be wearing the masks
15 days to slow the spread it'll all be
fine
360 days later you have to wear the
masks at least for another year
and there's no guarantee you'll probably
have to wear it
until the end of your life it's the
science it's the data
it's common sense i uh i'm not going to
wear the mask
there are certain instances in which i
have to wear the mask for instance when
i get on an airplane you cannot get on
an airplane unless you wear the mask
i am making a prudential calculation
that is better for me to get on the
airplane to go do a political event to
go talk about how
none of us should listen to fouchy
anymore uh i'm i think that that is
more valuable than taking the stand to
not where the masks on the airplane so
i'm making that prudential calculation
but generally speaking i don't wear the
masks i never wear the masks i'm aware
that i could get the virus
i take a lot of risks in my life i'm i
don't think i'm totally
never going to face any consequences
from anything i also think i could walk
outside and get
you know struck by a baby grand piano
falling from
the roof somewhere so i recognize there
many many risks i take
however i think given what we know about
the
the mortality rate from this virus
you know upper 90s some say over
99 percent we've heard 97 we've heard
over 99
from various studies i'm willing to take
my chances
we just got a very encouraging story out
of france
the oldest woman in europe
the oldest living woman in europe her
name is sister
andre she is a french
nun she is 116 years old
she is turning 117 tomorrow as she has
just
beaten covid she had kovid
at age 116. she is living
at the uh catherine la bourree
retirement home in toulon in southern
france
she had it she beat it
i wonder if she wears a mask the mask
has become a sort of
secular mantia you know it's like the
it's a it's a religious veil for the
religion of liberalism
i think uh sister andre wears an actual
fail like for a for true religion you
know
great on her what a wonderful story does
this mean that nobody can get the virus
no
does this mean no one can die from the
virus no
but these stories uh do give you another
perspective
and actually sister andre forget about
beating the virus i mean that's
wonderful
it is the case that you rarely meet an
unhealthy 116 year old
if you make it that far you've probably
got pretty good genes you're probably
pretty healthy
or it could be a miracle and if anyone's
going to have a you know access to
miracles
if anyone's going to know a thing or two
about miracles it would be a
nun but even more inspiring is her
take on the whole situation which i
think all of us who are
masking and cowering at home and
refusing to live our lives and canceling
thanksgiving and christmas and not
seeing her loved ones
we could learn a thing or two she said
when she got the virus she said no i
wasn't scared
because i wasn't scared to die i'm happy
to be with you
but i would wish to be somewhere else
join my big brother
and my grandfather and my grandmother
she actually said a couple of years ago
when she turned 115 she said i hope the
good lord takes me this year
well she wouldn't kill herself obviously
that would be a sin
but she said i've done life
and i don't think this is the end i
don't think we're just going to take a
dirt nap and turn to worm food
i think there is something beyond i
think there's a wonderful eternal reward
awaiting the faithful
and i want to go to that william f
buckley jr said this at the end of his
life
he said he was asked by charlie rose or
somebody he said
i'm done i'm tired of life
i wouldn't offer myself because it would
cause great pain to my friends and
family but i'm tired of it
i don't i i think there's something else
and i think i think there is something
else
but we appear to be stuck in a rut
politically
uh we're obviously stuck in a rut
because all we're talking about is
donald trump
i was told i was reliably informed
donald trump is no longer the president
so why are we
trying him for impeachment why is he the
only person we're talking about
why is why is the media still so focused
on him we can't
move past it it's like groundhog day
we're just stuck and stuck and stuck why
are we stuck in these covid
lockdowns we
slowed the spread we flattened the curve
we found a cure
why why are we never why are we being
told this is going to go on for another
year more than in a year
who knows why are we stuck in this rut
spiritually
i think you know religion comes down to
cultural questions culture comes down to
religious questions
at the base why are we
stuck here because i think a lot of
people think this is all there is
and when you have that that misordered
understanding that that fundamentally
flawed vision of the world then there's
there's really nowhere
if you if you feel there's nowhere for
your soul to go there's nowhere for you
to go right there's nowhere for your
society to go there's nowhere for your
politics to go there's no clear
aim there doesn't seem to be any real
purpose
so you get just a bunch of force
you get a bunch of silly fake
republicans
doing things they shouldn't be doing you
get a silly frivolous society doing
things it shouldn't be doing
got to reorder our priorities i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show